I really pressed hard at the craft
the work the acting classes
making sure that I was in martial arts
if I could add that to the repertoire
box
or the box of tools that I could dig
into if I needed to work on the piano
because one day I could play a character
where I played the piano just work on
the craft and don't necessarily worry
about the representation they will it'll
find you the right agent will find you
the right manager to write but now am I
struggling in terms of wanting even
bigger out of my career whether it's
people not where I'm at going you look
like you made it I don't know what make
it is you know I'm satisfied I'm so
humbled and thankful to God that I'm
where I'm at but there's always more and
so if you focus on
the more being attained by you making
sure that you do more for yourself
then I don't necessarily think the
representation should matter again they
definitely will always find you